did you talk for a second - about about
what happened with Lee aunt Whedon and
the allegations that were made by yeah
about that yeah this is pretty
incredible I I got a tip very late one
evening that Leanne tweetIn who I have
never met never communicated with never
had any association with was going to
come forward and make these allegations
against senator Franken allegations of
sexual assault so I go to Twitter and I
post it it's like one o'clock in the
morning 1:30 and the next morning she
has a press conference and she says
exactly what I was told by a source in
New York somebody very high up in the
Fox News organization not Sean Hannity
by the way if this was going to happen
the next thing I know Tom Arnold who I
guess the comedian Blais now out of work
puts up a tweet and says that Roger
stone coached Leeanne tweeted for weeks
about these allegations and therefore
Franklin should not step down guys I've
never met LeeAnn tweakin in my entire
life I never communicated with her or
anyone around her or camp it's entirely
bogus then Tom Arnold says I'm going to
produce proof and I'm still waiting okay
so you know the former governor of
Minnesota picks this up and he says
Roger stone should be investigated what
did you know I wanted to be Mel it and
then Joe Scarborough jumps on the
bandwagon guys it is really simple I
reported it I work for Infowars
as a journalist I do a show every day
for two hours a day you guys know how
that is yep and I reported it that is
the total extent of my role now maybe
maybe I think Tom Arnold had an
appearance coming up at the Comedy Store
on Somerset Boulevard he's trying to
hustle some tickets he thought he could
hook into some my publicity but I put up
or shut up maybe put up or shut up now
is the proof you know where's the proof
now we do have we do have Tom would you
be what we're willing to have Tom at
least tell you what his opinion
this is we have Tom on the phone if
that's okay I'd love to put him on Tom
hello buddy you're on with with Sam and
Jimin and Roger how are you all right
can we swear all this you can Roger it
okay I'm ready to put up Roger first of
all you're full of [ __ ]
second of all you act like you didn't
know anybody at KABC where Leanne worked
when you guilt by association buddies
call guilt by association where's your
proof oh wait hold on John Phillips
where is it I'm gonna lay out let me lay
it John Phillips is your good friend you
spent a lot of time and I've been on
John yeah pictures of you guys together
but in that the weekend you're kicked
off Twitter for calling people to see
words you stated John Phillips place
john philoponus jillian Barberie partner
cause you don't like acting that's not a
shadow that's not all this to me follow
me if that's false number two I'm not
the worst idea I've ever heard but so
far we've got a big nothing are you
telling that I ever topple ugly are you
telling you they don't over there
coworker I know John Phillips what does
that prove John about myself you say
this house Roger the previous summer I
stated within one weekend what does that
prove that's assuming McCarthy is there
right before the lead tweeted
announcement and with you're kicked off
Twitter that weekend I think he knows
what that was the weekend I worked with
LeAnn for years yeah I'm the only person
here that's worked with LeAnn had a
severance then you should learn how to
spell her name problem I saw the once
wrong but that's a you know what you
here for a guy that that does your
online hookup things it doesn't except
Patty's I think that's an insult you're
just upset because you can't get into
the party yeah I'm really worried about
that anyway so so Roger what happened is
you know he just wants to tear people
down
that's just thing and he wants me back
in the game his old partner Paul
Manafort made hundreds of millions of
dollars since 96 when they broke up
because Roger got that sex scandal that
he
right about on TV and he blames it on
alcohol it must be tough to be living
off of Rosen's residuals I wish anyway I
watched your documentary it said that
you're proud of that so here's the thing
Lian has had that picture for 10 years
she showed Sean Hannity in 2007 all of
us do about that picture all of us do
because I do the us whole thing - with
Alan and LeAnn so we knew about that
picture and she showed it to everybody
and you know cuz I would have no way of
knowing that everybody it wasn't a big
deal
and then suddenly some people at the
station said you know with this me -
movement which I am also involved in you
know there's this a time we can do
something with that picture and I know
this because I talked to LeAnn after
this happened and I think it and what
they did is the her producer that works
with her they started coaching her up
like I would coach her up on my show I
produced the best ask for shield period
I would say LeAnn just a segment about
this here's the bullet points to hit
tell me
let's try to dig something out of here
so she dug out the kiss thing and she
dug out the USO party and mm I'd were
she saw Al and she was so offended and
then when she was after I heard that
story when I talked to her person who
coached you who was your producer they
did a terrible job that was a USO dinner
honoring Al Franken that's a hard time
for you to go okay okay so that's their
stupid we're all Democrats okay did I
coach them - they all liars as well
Roger Roger Parmenter tommy tommy just
finished ant that way you were just
saying just Mike Craig you just clarify
who wasn't it did she answered you you
said who coached you what am I saying
she tell you LeAnn tell you that Roger
she called me LeAnn call the chief she
said that way and I believe her she
didn't realize she was being coached she
didn't know who Roger stone was but the
one thing she asked ABC is don't
announce it until I announce until I get
out there and announce it and Roger
stone tweeted about it before it
happened
that's because I'm a superb reporter but
you have no proof whatsoever that I've
ever been out people never matter never
talk to her never post a lawyer who's a
big
gossip calls us out here and several
people who shared it with me forever I
just oh he did use this day be used to
Russia deep we go on we go we go on
proof here Tom I have yeah Thomas you
could if you could let Roger respond
with it Roger do you have a Russian
alias
I have no Russian do yourself sir yeah
Tom's ask you did you do that that's a
fair question
yeah did I do it one more time is there
any information out on Al Franken buddy
information no absolutely no I think
about it when nobody was supposed to
know about it I I reported it because
that's what I do
Roger I didn't work the strategy make it
even happen I did you how did you find
out about it Roger
like how did you how did you get the
tractor and the tipster was not in Los
Angeles the tipster was in New York and
it turned out it was Sean Hannity
because he was involved in it with you
oh that's back Lea whole now we're now
we're shipping it yes and you shared it
with you everybody what I don't anymore
now it's Sean Hannity maybe it was
Rupert Murdoch okay but listen but but
no cuz I'm sure he would he would talk
to you Roger I think what happened is
you saw this something caveny you said
I'm gonna get on top of this so I get
back in the splash get back of the news
and so you jumped the gun they asked you
not to do it
the people at KBC you've had a bunch of
meetings about you said you got John
Phillips in major trouble down there you
can't eat he had this is a great very
clearly for my million dollars for
something true is it so I'm I look for
your next book in the fiction section at
Barnes and Noble
this isn't well anyway that's this is
what happened so it had even close we're
not even close around he took out al
franken because Al Franken was asking
too many good questions about Russia was
taken out because seven different women
accused him of sexual assaults at
roughly Democratic activists or did I
hang on Tom when when Leanne
told you that she was coached yes
specifically did she say kosher did she
say Roger stone did she say Sean Hannity
no it was the guy the guy I get their
two names see if I try to hear I have it
down
they work with her they work with
jillian Barberie who's John Phillips
co-host they work at ABC there's a
producer in the station
I'm looking up idea Tom let me just ask
you while you're doing that because I
again I'm going by boy you're both
saying I really don't have a lot of
prior knowledge of this is it possible
that you're mistaken that it wasn't
Roger
well it's Roger announced it before
would he know about it he had the
information but that makes you a
journalist that doesn't make you the
orchestrator of it that doesn't prove
that I you're here the woman that has
earnestly worked for in world wars
billions of what happened is his spread
they shared it with him now shared the
information is it Rob Roger put out
alert to everybody and equation so he'll
be ahead of the pack so he could live
just real at the same day that LeAnn
announced when LeAnn got back by the way
these guys did a shitty job with me and
I feel sorry for LeAnn too because they
coached her up she doesn't know what's
going on she thinks she's gonna change
women's lives they told her what to hit
what bullet points did she did what
outbreak could fire but she thought well
I could be like Jackie Speier who is
fired me who's a congresswoman and women
could come to me and then so they get
her get everything they want for her a
KBC they have her do the announcement
with their logo the background Roger so
to sit out all this information that's
das the age seven six other women come
forward I'll get a CLIA Roger hurry I'll
get it to you and he says that out is
the answer her and then they put her on
a plate to New York to do those
interviews which by the way by herself
they put this young woman under played
without her husband or kids no man for
the station they were done with her they
had used her she lives in New York she
does you know what show she's doing they
go oh you go to the beauty she's
throwing up she's sick oh you're going
over here and then he wonders what is
any what does that have to do with any
of this has to do with me what any of us
has to do what about those six other low
you hear anything from you are you are
the scumbag that perpetuated this whole
thing and put it out there I'm the
journal I'm the journalist reporter you
just came here detergent how okay hey
but you lied to me you said you heard it
from New York and I know you heard it
from John fills in the KBC knows your
job
at a big meeting up or shut up Tom prove
it no you just cuz we're letting Eli
over and over again doesn't make it true
okay but are you saying it's not true
that you never spoke to John Phillips
about that never said anything of kind I
spoke to him after it was announced the
following morning I didn't talk to him
prior to it because John Phillips is not
my source just because I know John
Philip just cuz I've been on his radio
show that doesn't prove that he was my
source that's called guilt by
association two and two equals five yeah
gay lovers real world model Roger stone
fantasy world that's what happened a lot
of people got in trouble about it and I
was actually worried for Jose Tom that
list is noted to make a movie called get
me Tom Arnold let me assure you well
anyway so I'm you know he and I and I
know the joy that he feels for or
starting this to take a band down I'm
not saying that the other people I'm not
judging anybody else to keep forward I'm
just saying this was the impetus this
was the build-up this was that she was
coached 100% like you would coach
somebody to do a segment
I love Lea but not by Roger stone that's
for sure I've never met the woman never
laid eyes on never stay by you other
people know you specifically said coach
for weeks by Roger stone and Johnson yes
you're very pretty that is very first we
live with my voice your very first tweet
yeah well anyway that that's what
happened there was weeks there's a
couple weeks she was coached out there
and Roger stone was involved and not
involved okay and he took the glory of
it you know the glory of taking someone
down and that's what Al Franken that's
what he did not for the better bit of
the country top for anything patriotic
because he's Roger no no we're not
removing removing men whose assault
women from public office that's a
patriotic act in my book this wasn't
done on the basis of just LeAnn tweetums
claims six other women have come forward
every single one of them a liberal
Democrat activist wrote a true but they
talked about hip patty tipper but or
something before you know whatever
I don't say that's appropriate but it's
not Harvey Weinstein and the truth is
yes okay we Tom I think we're gonna we I
wanted to give you a chance to weigh in
too because when people are talking
about each other it's better if they can
win we're gonna let you go but I
appreciate you calling in and and I
wanted you to give your side of as well
so both people could be heard Roger
started so full of [ __ ] he doesn't even
have full of [ __ ] but you know what time
are so full of [ __ ] his eyes are brown
dang funny show you do good Lord and
nail them all right tada work with the
microphone sub-type makes me go to sleep
it is the worst talk faster you think
you did get to get to coach it up how to
Norton coach you up a little bit by the
way I hope you find I hope to find work
good luck to another couch in Harlem
Roger I have an apartment in Harlem he
like a cyberstalk we tell people where I
you it's kind of kind of bizarre who do
you live lasting surgery victim it I
don't exactly where you live I don't
okay that's I know where you eat I
should hang all right Tom we appreciate
it and good luck with the baby I do the
kids actually okay buddy Delos